Well, it's June. Weddings everywhere, brides in white, little three-year-old nieces sent waddling down aisles throwing rose petals, vows that go on, perhaps a bit too long.
好吧，现在是六月了。到处都在举行婚礼，穿着白纱的新娘，三岁大的小侄女摇摇晃晃地走在过道上撒着花瓣，还有那些冗长到让人觉得或许太长了的誓词。
And how many of these happy couples are actually, underneath all of it, mismatched?
那么，在这一切表象之下，有多少对幸福的伴侣实际上并不匹配呢？
A huge number. It's frightening going to weddings.
数量极其庞大。参加婚礼是一件令人害怕的事。
Meet Alain de Botton, author of articles with titles like "Why You Will Marry the Wrong Person", and "How We End Up Marrying the Wrong Person", and two books about love. I was interested in talking to him because our radio show today is about making wrong choices. And he believes that when it comes to making the single most important decision many of us ever make in our lives, it is incredibly easy to screw it up-- much easier than we generally acknowledge.
来见见阿兰·德波顿，他写过像《为什么你会嫁错人》和《我们是如何嫁错人的》这类标题的文章，还写过两本关于爱情的书。我之所以想和他谈谈，是因为我们今天的电台节目主题就是关于做出错误选择。他认为，当我们做出人生中最重要的决定时，我们极其容易搞砸——这比我们通常认为的要容易得多。
You know, some of the reason why we marry the wrong people is that we don't really understand ourselves. I mean, sometimes I say to people, do you think you're easy to live with? People who are single. And the ones who say, yeah, yeah, I'm pretty easy to live with, it's just a question of finding the right person, massive alarm bell rings in my mind.
你知道，我们嫁错人的一些原因是，我们并不真正了解自己。我是说，有时我会问那些单身的人，你觉得自己好相处吗？而那些回答说“是啊，我很好相处，只是还没找到对的人”的人，我的脑海里会响起巨大的警报。
He says the problem is that it is not until we are actually married that we're in a situation where all the ways that we are hard to live with are truly revealed. All of our neuroses and flaws, all the tiny little things that vaguely remind us of our childhoods, and thus trigger peculiar and inappropriate behavior towards those we live with, that's what gets revealed by the marriage itself. Even if you lived together before marriage, he says, it's not the same. It doesn't give you that self-knowledge.
他说问题在于，直到我们真正结婚后，我们才处于一种状态，即我们身上所有难以相处的地方才会真正暴露出来。我们所有的神经质和缺陷，所有那些隐约让我们想起童年的细枝末节，从而引发对伴侣那种奇特且不恰当的行为，这些都是婚姻本身所揭示出来的。他说，即使你在婚前住在一起，那也不一样。那并不能让你获得这种自我认知。
And so we go into marriage unable to convey that knowledge to a partner. We don't understand them. They don't understand us. We don't understand what marriage is. Let's stress that.
因此，我们在步入婚姻时，无法向伴侣传达这种认知。我们不了解他们。他们也不了解我们。我们并不明白婚姻是什么。让我们强调这一点。
So what would you say to all the people getting married this month? What would you tell them?
那么，你会对这个月结婚的所有人说些什么呢？你会告诉他们什么？
Be incredibly forgiving for the weird behavior that's going to start coming out. You will be very unhappy in lots of ways. Your partner will fail to understand you.
要对即将出现的那些怪异行为保持极大的宽容。你在很多方面都会感到非常不快乐。你的伴侣会无法理解你。
If you're understood in maybe, I don't know, 60% of your soul by your partner, that's fantastic. Don't expect that it's going to be 100%. Of course you will be lonely.
如果你的灵魂能有百分之六十被你的伴侣理解，那已经是太棒了。不要指望能达到百分之百。当然，你会感到孤独。
You will often be in despair. You will sometimes think it's the worst decision in your life. That's fine. That's not a sign your marriage has gone wrong.
你经常会陷入绝望。有时你甚至会觉得这是你一生中最糟糕的决定。没关系。那并不代表你的婚姻出了问题。
It's a sign that it's normal, it's on track. And many of the hopes that took you into the marriage will have to die in order for the marriage to continue. That some of the headiness and expectations will have to die.
这说明它很正常，正在正轨上。而许多带你走进婚姻的希望将不得不破灭，婚姻才能继续下去。一些令人陶醉的期待将不得不消亡。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Most of all--
最重要的是——
I'm laughing cause this is so dark.
我笑是因为这太黑暗了。
It's very dark. But in love, darkness is a real friend of relationships. Because so many of the problems of love come from unwarranted optimism. And so we need to be dark about so many things.
这确实非常黑暗。但在爱情中，黑暗是人际关系的真正朋友。因为爱情中的许多问题都源于毫无根据的乐观。所以，我们需要对很多事情保持悲观。
OK, I'm going to stop the tape right there and come in to say, I know he's going on a little bit here. And by the way, mazel tov to everybody getting married this month. But I'm a married person. And OK, just speaking for myself, I find this tear that he's on to be one of the most accurate descriptions of marriage I've ever heard-- no judging please-- and also, in its own way, kind of hopeful. But we'll get to that. Anyway, back to the tape.
好了，我要在这里暂停录音，插一句，我知道他有点唠叨了。顺便说一下，祝这个月结婚的每一对新人新婚快乐。但我是一个已婚人士。好吧，仅代表我自己，我发现他所说的这段话是我所听过的对婚姻最准确的描述之一——请不要评判——而且在某种程度上，也带有一种希望。但我们稍后再说。不管怎样，回到录音。
Let me say, you'll have noticed that I've got a British accent. Now, Britain doesn't do many things well. We fail at a lot of things. But one of the things we excel at-- perhaps almost on an international scale-- is melancholy. We do melancholy really well. The weather helps.
容我说一句，你会注意到我有英国口音。英国其实没什么擅长的事。我们在很多事情上都失败了。但我们最擅长的一件事——也许是在国际范围内——就是忧郁。我们真的很擅长忧郁。天气帮了大忙。
And I think that there are aspects of a good marriage that should encompass a kind of melancholy, as we realize that we're trying to do such a complex thing with someone. We are trying to find our best friend, our ideal sexual partner, our co-household manager, perhaps our co-parent. And we're expecting that all this will miraculously go well together. Of course it can. We're not going to be able to get it all right. There will be many areas of misunderstanding and failure. And a certain amount of sober melancholy is a real asset when heading forth into the land of love.
我认为一段美好的婚姻中应当包含一种忧郁，因为我们意识到，我们正试图与某人共同完成一件极其复杂的事情。我们试图寻找最好的朋友、理想的性伴侣、共同的家庭管理者，或许还有共同的父母角色。我们指望这一切能奇迹般地和谐统一。当然可以。我们不可能把一切都做得完美。会有很多误解和失败的地方。当踏入爱河时，一定程度清醒的忧郁是一笔真正的财富。
And so to sum up, he says we choose the wrong spouse because we don't actually understand what marriage is really going to be like. Because we do not know ourselves. And in addition, we idealize our spouse. We make hasty choices about who we'll marry because being single can be so unpleasant. And because, rather than analyzing and thinking all those things through, instead we just follow our feelings. We go on gut. We go on instinct. Which, to Alain's way of thinking, is obviously inadequate to the task at hand.
总结一下，他说我们之所以选择错误的配偶，是因为我们并不真正了解婚姻会是什么样子。因为我们不了解自己。此外，我们将配偶理想化了。我们仓促地做出结婚决定，因为单身的生活可能非常令人不快。而且，我们没有去分析和思考所有这些事情，而是仅仅追随自己的感受。我们凭直觉行事。我们凭本能行事。而在阿兰看来，这对于手头的任务来说显然是不够的。
I mean, imagine if I said I'm going to try to land a 777 tomorrow, I'm going to touch down at San Francisco airpot by intuition. Or if I said I'm going to perform quite a complicated surgical procedure this afternoon by intuition, sounds mad. Nevertheless, we accept that people are going to say, I'm going to run this major part of my life called my love life by intuition.
我是说，想象一下，如果我说我明天要尝试驾驶一架777客机，我要凭直觉在旧金山机场降落。或者如果我说我今天下午要凭直觉进行一台相当复杂的外科手术，听起来太疯狂了。然而，我们却接受人们说，我将凭直觉经营我生活中这非常重要的一部分，即我的爱情生活。
Now, I know that we've all heard some of these things, OK? I think every couple now knows that it's not going be great all the time. Every couple is told it's going to be hard. You're going to have to work at it.
好了，我知道我们都听说过这些，对吧？我想每一对情侣现在都知道，婚姻不可能一直都那么美好。每一对情侣都被告知婚姻会很艰难。你必须为之付出努力。
But the radical message that Alain de Botton brings is even if you work at it, you're not going to be that successful. It's going to be a mix of unhappiness and happiness with way more unhappiness than you think before you get married. And a good partnership is one where both people have realistic expectations about all that.
但阿兰·德波顿带来的激进信息是，即使你付出努力，你也不会那么成功。它将是苦乐参半的，而且在结婚前你所想的不快乐要多得多。而一段良好的伙伴关系是双方对这一切都有现实期望的关系。
A good partnership he writes, "Is not so much between two healthy people. There aren't many of those on the planet. It's one between two demented people who have had the skill or luck to find a non-threatening conscious accommodation between their relative insanities." The standard question on an early dinner date he says should be simply, "And how are you crazy?"
他在书中写道，一段良好的伙伴关系“并不存在于两个健康的人之间。在这个星球上那样的人不多。它存在于两个疯狂的人之间，他们有技巧或运气找到一种相互间不会构成威胁的清醒妥协。”他说，在第一次约会时的标准问题应该仅仅是：“你是怎么个疯法？”
I mean, relationships markedly improve when two people can make almost a blanket avowal-- we're both kind of crazy.
我是说，当两个人几乎可以公开承认——我们都有点疯——的时候，关系会显著改善。
You're married, right?
你结婚了，对吧？
I'm married.
我结婚了。
What's your wife say about all this?
你妻子怎么看这一切？
Look, she's very funny. She's a pessimistic realist. On our 10th wedding anniversary, she dressed in black. And she said, it was a funeral for many of her hopes. So she's quite dark too. But we're actually very hopeful about the course of love.
你看，她非常风趣。她是一个悲观的现实主义者。在我们结婚十周年纪念日，她穿上了黑色的衣服。她说，这是为了她许多希望的葬礼。所以她也很阴郁。但我们实际上对爱情的走向非常有希望。
And in your marriage, did you both go through a process of entering the marriage with one idea, a very idealized idea, of what marriage would be, and then you came to this other idea?
在你们的婚姻中，你们是否都经历了一个过程：带着一个想法，一个非常理想化的婚姻想法步入婚姻，然后又转向了另一个想法？
Yes. I had absolutely no idea about how to love. I hadn't had many relationships. And I literally used to think that the only problem, the only difficulty of love was finding this person called the right person.
是的。我完全不知道如何去爱。我没谈过多少恋爱。我真的曾经认为爱情唯一的难题、唯一的困难就是找到那个所谓的“对的人”。
And they'd come into my life, and then we'd just understand one another totally. We would understand each other without needing to speak. We wouldn't have any arguments. We wouldn't have any arguments over money or practicalities. And I think we had a succession of crises and moments of fear, where we really thought we had married the wrong person.
然后他们会走进我的生活，我们就完全理解彼此了。我们无需言语就能理解对方。我们不会有任何争吵。我们不会为钱或琐事争吵。我想我们经历了一系列的危机和恐惧时刻，那时我们真的以为自己嫁错了人。
Is there a more general rule here? Do most of us make mistakes in other huge decisions in our lives because we don't know ourselves?
这里有一个更普遍的规则吗？我们大多数人在生活中做出其他重大决定时是否也因为不了解自己而犯错？
The other area where we make major bad decisions based on a lack of self knowledge-- and it's exactly the same principle-- is work. Work and love, and the two very similar. Because in both areas, we abandon the field totally to intuition. You're supposed to find your work by a kind of special calling, by a special pull. And in fact, in order to find a job that you can love, you have to understand so much about yourself, your own character, your own nature, let alone the world of work itself.
另一个基于缺乏自我认知而做出重大错误决定的领域——原理完全一样——是工作。工作和爱情非常相似。因为在这两个领域，我们完全放弃了理性，交给直觉。你本应该通过某种特殊的召唤、特殊的吸引力来找到你的工作。但事实上，为了找到一份你真正热爱的工作，你必须非常了解自己、自己的性格、自己的本质，更不用说工作本身的世界了。
And so he says, we choose wrong in not one, but two of the biggest things we ever decide in our lives. And then we muddle our way through. Today on our show, as some of Alain's countrymen who voted for the Brexit are telling reporters they regret their votes now that they see the reality of what it is, we have stories of people making the wrong choices.
所以他说，我们在人生中最大的两件事上都做出了错误的选择。然后我们糊里糊涂地过着。今天在我们的节目中，正如一些投票支持英国脱欧的阿兰的同胞在看到现实后告诉记者他们后悔投票一样，我们有一些人做出错误选择的故事。
And in the stories we have today, the stakes are high-- like, for instance, the career of one of the greatest basketball players who ever lived, like the outcome of the presidential election. And in every story, it could have gone differently. The right choice was out there, right in front of them. They saw it and they rejected the right choice. Something stopped them. What stops us from choosing the best thing for us? So interesting, right? Answers from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
在我们今天的故事里，赌注很高——比如，历史上最伟大的篮球运动员之一的职业生涯，比如总统大选的结果。在每一个故事里，本来都可以有不同的走向。正确的选择就在那里，就在他们面前。他们看到了，却拒绝了正确的选择。是什么阻止了他们？是什么阻止了我们为自己做出最好的选择？真有意思，对吧？来自芝加哥WBEZ的回答，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act 1-- "Swish, Miss". So this first wrong choice we're going to talk about in our show, it was made by an athlete who absolutely knew what the right choice could do for him. This story comes from Malcolm Gladwell, who's best known as the author of books like The Tipping Point . Malcolm has started a new podcast called Revisionist History . And he let us adapt one of his stories to play for you now. Here he is.
第一幕——“刷，错失”。我们要讨论的这个第一个错误选择，是由一位完全知道正确选择能为他带来什么的运动员做出的。这个故事来自马尔科姆·格拉德威尔，他最为人所知的身份是《引爆点》等书的作者。马尔科姆开启了一个名为《修正主义历史》的新播客。他让我们改编了他的一个故事来播给你听。他来了。
The greatest game of basketball anyone has ever played was in Hershey, Pennsylvania, March 2nd, 1962.
最伟大的篮球比赛发生在1962年3月2日的宾夕法尼亚州赫尔希。
Here's the big fourth quarter. And everybody's thinking how many does Wilt got to get? He's got 69 gone in. Here's the pass to him. He's got another one. Any time--
这是关键的第四节。每个人都在想张伯伦能拿到多少分？他已经得了69分了。球传给他了。他又进了一个。任何时候——
Cold winter night, just over 4,000 people in the stands. Philadelphia Warriors vs. The New York Knicks.
寒冷的冬夜，看台上只有4000多人。费城勇士队对阵纽约尼克斯队。
--defense honest. When [INAUDIBLE] that have the good shot, they're taking it. But mostly they're setting up the big man.
——让防守者保持警惕。当[听不清]有空位投篮机会时，他们就会投。但大多数情况下，他们都是在为那个大个子做球。
The star of the Warriors was a man named Wilt Chamberlain-- no doubt you've heard of him-- 7'1", 275 pounds. For sheer physical presence, there has probably never been anyone like Wilt. There are lots of seven footers who play basketball, who are basically on the court purely because they're seven feet tall. They're clumsy and ungainly.
勇士队的明星是一位叫威尔特·张伯伦的人——毫无疑问你听说过他——身高7英尺1英寸，体重275磅。就纯粹的身体天赋而言，可能从来没有谁像威尔特那样。有很多七英尺高的人打篮球，他们纯粹是因为身高才上场。他们笨拙且不灵巧。
Chamberlain was not like that. He was as big as an oak tree and as graceful as a ballet dancer. That season, 1961 to 1962, he ended up averaging more than 50 points a game. That record will never be broken.
张伯伦不是那样的人。他像橡树一样高大，又像芭蕾舞演员一样优雅。那个赛季，即1961到1962赛季，他场均得分超过了50分。那个记录将永远不会被打破。
Chamberlain with a rebound. Taps it in. Chamberlain taps it in--
张伯伦抢到篮板。补进。张伯伦补进——
So March 2nd, Wilt was hungover. He'd been out all night with a woman he picked up at a bar. That's classic Wilt, too.
所以3月2日那天，威尔特宿醉了。他整晚都在酒吧里和一个女人鬼混。那也是典型的威尔特。
He would later claim to have slept with 20,000 women in his life. And when he said that, lots of people did the math and said, there was no way that was possible, given the fact that there are only 24 hours in a day, and Wilt only lived to the age of 63. But even the skeptics were like, well, maybe it's 10,000 or 8,000. It was an argument over whether it was an unbelievably high number, or merely an incredibly high number.
他后来声称自己一生中与两万名女性发生过关系。当他说这话时，很多人算了算，觉得这是不可能的，因为一天只有24小时，而且威尔特只活到了63岁。但即使是怀疑者也说，好吧，也许是一万或八千。争论点在于这到底是一个难以置信的高数字，还是仅仅是一个极其惊人的高数字。
[INAUDIBLE] ...happy to be with you on this historic occasion.
[听不清]……很高兴能在这一历史性时刻与你们在一起。
So back to the game in question. Chamberlain makes his first five shots and has 23 points at the end of the first quarter. At halftime, he has 41 points. No one's thinking history just yet. But then, by the end of the third quarter, he has 69 points. And he keeps going and going and going.
回到那场比赛。张伯伦前五次投篮全中，第一节结束时已得23分。半场结束时，他得了41分。还没有人想到历史。但到了第三节结束，他已经拿到了69分。而且他还在继续，继续，继续。
The rebound, [INAUDIBLE]. That's directly into Chamber-- he made it! He made it! He made it! A different dunk! He made it! The fans are all over the floor!
篮板，[听不清]。直接传给张伯伦——他投中了！他投中了！他投中了！又一个扣篮！他投中了！球迷们全都冲进场内了！
100 points, the most anyone has ever scored in a professional basketball game. And here is the most incredible thing about it-- he shot brilliantly from the foul line, made 87.5% of his shots. The reason that's incredible is that Chamberlain was a horrendous free throw shooter, the worst.
100分，这是职业篮球赛中个人单场最高得分。这里最不可思议的事情是——他在罚球线上表现神勇，87.5%的罚球命中。之所以不可思议，是因为张伯伦是一个糟糕的罚球手，最差的那种。
He was a man who could score at will with two and sometimes three defenders draped all over his body. But put him all alone, 15 feet from the basket, and he was hopeless. There were seasons in his career where he shot 40% from the free throw line. That's terrible.
他是一个可以在两名甚至三名防守者覆盖下随心所欲得分的人。但让他独自一人站在篮筐15英尺外，他就无能为力了。他职业生涯中有些赛季的罚球命中率仅为40%。太糟糕了。
But this season, Chamberlain changes tactics. He starts to shoot his foul shots underhanded. He doesn't release the ball up by his forehead.
但这个赛季，张伯伦改变了战术。他开始用双手从下往上投罚球。他不再把球举到额头位置投篮。
He holds the ball between his knees and flicks it towards the basket from a slight crouch. Some people call that a granny shot. And all of a sudden, he's a pretty good free throw shooter.
他把球放在膝盖之间，在轻微蹲伏的情况下向篮筐弹去。有些人称之为“奶奶投篮”。突然之间，他变成了一个相当不错的罚球手。
He gets up to more than 60%. And that special night in Hershey, Pennsylvania, he's an incredible free throw shooter.
他罚球命中率提高到了60%以上。而在宾夕法尼亚州赫尔希的那个特别的夜晚，他简直是一个不可思议的罚球手。
Chamberlain on the line. Foul shot, up in the air. He has 84.
张伯伦站在罚球线上。罚球，球在空中。他已经得了84分了。
He makes 28 free throws, the most anyone has ever made in a regular season game in NBA history.
他罚中了28个球，是NBA历史上个人单场常规赛罚球命中数最多的纪录。
20? What?
20个？什么？
28. He made 28 out of 30.
28个。他30次罚球进了28个。
You beat that?
你能破这个吗？
It's 30 or 32, yeah.
是30个还是32个，是的。
That's Rick Barry speaking. He played in the NBA at the same time as Chamberlain, also a Hall of Famer, an absolutely unstoppable scorer from almost anywhere on the court, especially the foul line. I met him at his condo in South Carolina earlier this year.
那是里克·巴里在说话。他和张伯伦同一时期在NBA打球，也是名人堂成员，是一个几乎在球场任何位置都无法阻挡的得分手，尤其是在罚球线上。今年早些时候，我在他南卡罗来纳州的公寓里见到了他。
He was living there so he could follow his son, Canyon, who was playing basketball for the College of Charleston at the time. Barry is 72, 6'8" tall, barrel chest, legs that look like he had special extensions put on them. And that thing that great athletes have and never seem to lose, which is that they kind of glide across the floor, like they have wheels on. What Rick Barry will tell you is that shooting underhanded is simply a better way to make foul shots. And he knows that because he was one of the greatest foul shooters of all time.
他住在那儿是为了追踪他儿子坎宁的比赛，坎宁当时在查尔斯顿学院打篮球。巴里72岁，身高6英尺8英寸，胸膛宽厚，那双腿看起来像是加装了特殊的延长件。而且伟大运动员身上那种似乎永远不会消失的特质——那就是他们走起路来仿佛脚下装了轮子，在球场上滑行。里克·巴里会告诉你的是，下手位投篮实际上是罚球更好的方式。他之所以知道这一点，是因为他是史上最伟大的罚球手之一。
I missed 10 in one season and 9 in another, in the whole season.
我有一个赛季只投丢了10个，另一个赛季只丢了9个，整个赛季加起来。
To put that in perspective, if LeBron James-- who may be the greatest player of his generation-- if he was as good from the foul line as Rick Barry, he would have scored hundreds-- in fact-- over 1,000 more points over the course of his career.
换个角度来看，如果勒布朗·詹姆斯——他可能是他那一代最伟大的球员——如果他的罚球能有里克·巴里那么好，他在职业生涯中会多得数百个——事实上——超过1000分。
I think I shot 93.5 or something and 94.7, something like that.
我想我的命中率是93.5%还是94.7%，差不多是那样。
And Rick Barry only shot underhanded.
而里克·巴里只用下手位投篮。
From the physics standpoint, it's a much better way to shoot. Less things that can go wrong, less things that you have to worry about repeating properly in order for it to be successful. But the other thing is, is that who walks around like this?
从物理学角度来看，这是一种更好的投篮方式。出错的可能性更小，你不需要担心如何重复动作才能成功。但另一件事是，谁会这样走来走去？
Barry put his hands up in the air, holding an imaginary ball, mimicking the way everyone else shoots free throws.
巴里把手举到空中，拿着一个想象中的球，模仿其他人罚球的样子。
This is not a natural position. When I shoot underhand in free throws, where are my arms? Hanging straight down, the way they are normally. And so I'm totally and completely relaxed. It's not in the situation where I have to worry about my muscles getting tense or tight. And then the shot itself, it's a much softer shot. So many of my shots, even if they're a little off, they hit so nice and soft, and they'll still fall in the basket.
这姿势一点也不自然。当我用下手位投球罚球时，我的手臂在哪里？自然下垂，就像平时一样。所以我完全放松。我不需要担心肌肉紧张。而且投篮本身，这是一个更柔和的投篮。我很多球，即使偏了一点点，它们碰到篮圈时也会很软，依然会掉进篮筐里。
The soft bounce.
那种柔和的弹跳。
Much softer touch. And so you have a little bit more margin for error than when you shoot overhand.
手感柔和得多。所以你比上手位投篮多了一点容错率。
So Wilt Chamberlain switches to a better shooting technique. It pays off in the greatest basketball game ever played. He's playing the way that Rick Barry proved basketball players ought to play.
所以威尔特·张伯伦改用了更好的投篮技术。这在篮球史上最伟大的比赛中得到了回报。他打的是里克·巴里证明过篮球运动员应该打的方式。
Then, inexplicably, Wilt Chamberlain stops shooting underhanded. And what happens? He goes back to being a terrible foul shooter.
然后，令人费解的是，威尔特·张伯伦停止了下手位投篮。结果呢？他又回到了那个糟糕的罚球手。
Let's think about what he did for a moment. Chamberlain had a problem. He tested out a possible solution.
让我们思考一下他当时的做法。张伯伦有一个问题。他测试了一个可能的解决方案。
The solution worked. And all of a sudden, he's fixed his biggest weakness as a player. This is not a trivial matter.
解决方案奏效了。突然间，他解决了自己作为球员最大的弱点。这不是一件小事。
If you're a basketball player and you can't hit your free throws, you're an incredible liability to your team, particularly at the end of close games. The other side simply fouls you every time you touch the ball because they know you'll miss your free throw and they'll get the ball back. If you can't hit your foul shots, it means you can't be used in a tight game.
如果你是一个篮球运动员，你无法命中罚球，你对球队来说就是一个巨大的累赘，尤其是在比分胶着的比赛末段。对方只要一碰你球就故意对你犯规，因为他们知道你会投丢罚球，他们就能拿回球权。如果你罚不进，这意味着你在关键比赛中无法上场。
You know what Chamberlain's coach said to him about his free throws? "If you were a 90% shooter, we might never lose." They didn't play on the same team, but Rick Barry got to know Chamberlain pretty well.
你知道张伯伦的教练是怎么对他说罚球的吗？“如果你能有90%的命中率，我们可能永远不会输。”他们不在同一支球队，但里克·巴里相当了解张伯伦。
I got to know him, you know? And I just joked with him and said, your technique was terrible. But I mean, had you stuck with it-- I mean, there's no telling what he would have done. I mean, the numbers he would have put up would have been insane. Because the only way they defended him was to foul him.
我很了解他，你知道吗？我只是和他开了个玩笑，说你的技术太烂了。但我的意思是，如果你坚持下去——我的意思是，很难说他会创造什么样的成就。我的意思是，他打出的数据会是疯狂的。因为他们防守他唯一的办法就是对他犯规。
Chamberlain had every incentive in the world to keep shooting free throws underhanded, and he didn't. I think when people don't do the thing they ought to do, we assume it's because of ignorance. This is not that. This is doing something dumb even though you're fully aware that you're doing something dumb.
张伯伦拥有世界上一切动力去坚持下手位投篮，但他没有。我认为当人们不做他们应该做的事情时，我们假设是因为无知。但事实并非如此。这是在明知故犯，即使你完全意识到自己在做愚蠢的事情。
By the way, there had been countless players like Chamberlain, players who could have been transcendent, devastating, if only they had been open to taking foul shots a different way. Take Shaquille O'Neal, up there with Wilt Chamberlain as one of the greatest NBA centers of all time, but an absolutely horrendous free throw shooter. Shaq even inspired a term, Hack-a-Shaq, which means intentionally fouling Shaquille O'Neal-- or any other terrible free throw shooter-- in order to put them on the foul line, where they're likely to miss their shots. Shaq's inability to shoot free throws drove Rick Barry nuts. Barry tried to reason with him.
顺便说一下，像张伯伦这样的球员数不胜数，如果他们能开放心态采取不同的罚球方式，他们本可以成为那种卓越、毁灭性的球员。拿沙奎尔·奥尼尔来说，他和威尔特·张伯伦一样是NBA史上最伟大的中锋之一，但却是一个绝对糟糕的罚球手。奥尼尔甚至催生了一个词，“Hack-a-Shaq”（砍鲨战术），意思是故意对沙奎尔·奥尼尔——或任何其他糟糕的罚球手——犯规，以把他们送上罚球线，因为他们很可能会投丢。奥尼尔无法命中罚球让里克·巴里抓狂。巴里试图说服他。
Oh, you actually talked to Shaquille  O'Neal?
哦，你真的和沙奎尔·奥尼尔谈过？
Oh, I tried to get Shaq to change.
哦，我试着让奥尼尔改变。
Shaquille O'Neal?
沙奎尔·奥尼尔？
Shaquille O'Neal, when I tried to get him to do it, he said, forget it. I'd rather shoot 0 than shoot underhanded.
沙奎尔·奥尼尔，当我试图让他这么做时，他说，算了吧。我宁愿得0分也不愿下手位投篮。
And I'm just fascinated by that.
对此我非常着迷。
I don't understand that.
我不明白这一点。
No one shoots underhanded. Not even Barry's teammates followed his lead, people who saw him shoot that way every day and never miss.
没人会下手位投篮。甚至巴里的队友也没有跟随他的脚步，他们每天都看着他那样投篮，而且从不投失。
One guy, only--
一个人，只有一个——
One man, who's that?
一个人，是谁？
George Johnson, my teammate with the Warriors. I think he was like, 48%, 50%, something like that. And I worked with him for one season. I didn't get to stay with him.
乔治·约翰逊，我在勇士队的队友。我想他的命中率大概是48%、50%左右。我和他一起练了一个赛季。但我没能一直和他在一起。
He didn't get the technique down as much as I'd like it. But I think eventually, a season or two later, I think George actually shot 80%. I could actually look it up. It would be interesting to see what he did. I'll get George Johnson's stats here. Let me see. George Johnson's stats.
他没能像我想要的那样完全掌握这项技术。但我想最终，一两个赛季后，我想乔治实际上达到了80%的命中率。我可以去查一下。看看他做了什么会很有意思。我去查一下乔治·约翰逊的数据。让我看看。乔治·约翰逊的数据。
Sorry, Rick, I didn't get that.
抱歉，里克，我没查到。
Whoops. OK. Stats for George Johnson, NBA.
哎呀。好吧。乔治·约翰逊的NBA数据。
Here are George Johnson's stats from the 2015 NFL season.
这是乔治·约翰逊2015赛季的NFL数据。
NFL. That's great. Wrong guy, wrong season. But anyway, we'll look it up. It's interesting.
NFL。真棒。搞错了人，搞错了赛季。但不管怎样，我们会查出来的。很有趣。
It's actually more dramatic than Barry said. Johnson was once a 40% free throw shooter. And he ended up over 80%-- twice as good.
这实际上比巴里说的更戏剧性。约翰逊曾经是一个命中率40%的罚球手。最终他超过了80%——水平翻了一倍。
But I mean, what about one your high school team? Did anyone throw underhand?
但我的意思是，你高中球队里有人下手位投篮吗？
Oh no, nobody. No. I've only had one guy ever come to me. An NBA guy came to me. I won't tell you his name.
哦没有，根本没人。没有。只有一个家伙来找我。有个NBA球员来找我。我就不告诉你他的名字了。
But he came to me, he asked me to work with him. I did it. I worked with him. I had him shooting really well. And he never had the nerve to go back and do it when he went back.
但他来找我，请我指导他。我做了。我指导了他。我让他练得投得非常好。但他回去之后就没胆量再去做了。
Can you tell me his name?
你能告诉我他的名字吗？
Nah, I don't want to tell his name. It's not fair to him.
不，我不想告诉他的名字。对他不公平。
I don't want to say his name. It's not fair to him, like it's some kind of dark, shameful secret. College basketball is no different.
我不想说出他的名字。这对他不公平，就像这是一种黑暗的、羞耻的秘密。大学篮球也没什么不同。
Out of the thousands of college basketball players last season, there were-- as far as I can tell-- just two who shot underhanded. One is a Nigerian-American who played for Louisville, named Chinanu Onuaku. The other, is Canyon Barry, who played for the College of Charleston, and who-- in case you missed this earlier-- happens to be Rick Barry's son. In other words, there are only two conditions under which people will try the underhanded free throw. One, if their family is from another continent, and two, if they're an offspring of Rick Barry.
在上赛季的数千名大学篮球运动员中，就我所知，只有两个人采用了下手位投篮。一个是为路易斯维尔效力的尼日利亚裔美国人，叫奇纳努·奥努阿库。另一个是坎宁·巴里，他在查尔斯顿学院打球，顺便提一下——如果你刚才没听到的话——他正好是里克·巴里的儿子。换句话说，人们尝试下手位罚球只有两种情况。第一，如果他们的家庭来自另一个大洲；第二，如果他们是里克·巴里的后代。
Here's why I went all the way to South Carolina to talk to Rick Barry-- not because I'm obsessed with basketball, although I am-- but because the strange story of the underhanded free throw is a really good way of thinking about something that has always puzzled me. Why do some good ideas spread and others go nowhere? We like to think that good ideas will spread because they're good, because their advantages are obvious.
这就是我为什么大老远跑到南卡罗来纳州和里克·巴里谈话的原因——不是因为我沉迷于篮球，尽管我确实沉迷——而是因为下手位罚球这个奇怪的故事是思考一个一直困扰我的问题的绝佳方式。为什么一些好主意会传播开来，而另一些则毫无动静？我们倾向于认为好主意会传播，因为它们很好，因为它们的优点显而易见。
But that's plainly not true. So why don't they? Or to put it another way, what is it about Rick Barry that allowed him to shoot this way? And what is it about Wilt Chamberlain and all the others that made them resist?
但事实显然并非如此。那么为什么不传播呢？或者换个说法，里克·巴里有什么不同之处使他能那样投篮？而威尔特·张伯伦和其他人又是什么原因使他们拒绝呢？
Let me try out a theory on you. It's from a sociologist named Mark Granovetter. Granovetter is one of the greatest social theorists of his generation. If you're an academic groupie like I am, Granovetter is like James Dean.
让我给你讲一个理论。它来自一位叫马克·格兰诺维特的社会学家。格兰诺维特是他那一代最伟大的社会理论家之一。如果你像我一样是学术迷，格兰诺维特简直就是詹姆斯·迪恩。
So Granovetter came up with something called the Threshold Model of Collective Behavior. He was trying to answer the question of why people do things out of character. He used riots as his big example.
所以格兰诺维特提出了一个名为“集体行为阈值模型”的东西。他试图回答为什么人们会表现得不像自己。他以骚乱作为他主要的例子。
Why do otherwise law-abiding citizens suddenly throw rocks through windows? Before Granovetter came along, sociologists tried to explain that kind of puzzling behavior in terms of beliefs. So the thinking went-- you and I have a set of beliefs. But when you throw the rock through the window, something powerful must have happened in the moment to change your beliefs. Something about the crowd transforms the way you think. Here's Granovetter explaining that idea.
为什么守法的公民会突然向窗户投掷石块？在格兰诺维特之前，社会学家试图用信念来解释那种令人困惑的行为。想法是这样的——你和我有一套信念。但当你向窗户投掷石块时，在那一刻一定发生了什么强大的事情改变了你的信念。关于人群的某些东西改变了你的思维方式。这是格兰诺维特解释这个想法。
There was a lot of intellectual tradition that said that when people got into a crowd their independent judgment went out the window, and that they somehow became creatures of the crowd, and that there was some kind of miasma of irrationality that would settle over people. And they would act in ways that they would never act if they were by themselves or they weren't influenced by the mob mentality.
过去有很多学术传统认为，当人们进入人群时，他们的独立判断力就会丧失，他们会以某种方式成为人群的生物，某种非理性的瘴气会笼罩在人们身上。他们会做出如果他们独自一人或没有受到暴民心态影响时永远不会做出的行为。
But Granovetter doesn't buy it. He doesn't think that being part of the mob casts some kind of spell that makes everyone irrational. He says, it's all about thresholds.
但格兰诺维特不买账。他不认为成为暴民的一部分会施加什么咒语让每个人都变得非理性。他说，这全关乎阈值。
Now, what does Granovetter mean by that word, "threshold"? A belief is an internal thing. It's a position we've taken in our head or in our heart.
现在，格兰诺维特用“阈值”这个词是什么意思？信念是内在的东西。这是我们在脑海或心中建立的立场。
But unlike beliefs, thresholds are external. They're about peer pressure. Your threshold is the number of people who have to do something before you join in.
但与信念不同，阈值是外在的。它们与同辈压力有关。你的阈值是指在你加入之前必须有多少人先做某事。
Granovetter makes two crucial arguments. The first is that thresholds and beliefs sometimes overlap. But a lot of the time, they don't.
格兰诺维特提出了两个关键论点。第一个是阈值和信念有时会重叠。但很多时候，它们不会。
When your teenage son is driving 100 miles an hour at midnight with three of his friends in your Toyota Camry, it's not because he believes that driving 100 miles per hour is a good idea. In that moment, his beliefs are irrelevant. His behavior is guided by his threshold.
当你十几岁的儿子在午夜开着你的丰田凯美瑞，车里载着三个朋友，以每小时100英里的速度行驶时，那并不是因为他认为时速100英里是个好主意。在那一刻，他的信念并不重要。他的行为由他的阈值引导。
An 18-year-old may be drunk at midnight in a car with three of his friends. That person has a really, really low threshold. It doesn't take a lot of encouragement to get him to do something stupid.
一个18岁的孩子可能在午夜醉醺醺地坐在载着三个朋友的车里。那个人阈值非常非常低。不需要太多的鼓励就能让他做蠢事。
Granovetter's second point is just as important. Everyone's threshold is different. There are plenty of radicals and troublemakers who might need only slight encouragement to throw that rock. Their threshold is really low.
格兰诺维特的第二个观点同样重要。每个人的阈值都不同。有很多激进分子和惹事生非者，可能只需要一点点鼓励就会去投掷石块。他们的阈值真的很低。
But think about your grandmother. She might well need her sister, her grandchildren, her neighbors, her friends from church, all of them to be throwing rocks before she would even dream of joining in. She's got a high threshold. The riot has to be going on for a very long time and has to involve a whole lot of people before grandma will join in. But there are times when even grandmothers might throw rocks through windows.
但想想你的祖母。她很可能需要她的姐妹、孙辈、邻居、教会的朋友，所有这些人都在投掷石块，她才会梦想加入。她的阈值很高。骚乱必须持续很长时间，且必须涉及非常多的人，祖母才会加入。但在某些时候，即使是祖母也可能向窗户投掷石块。
Granovetter's theory explained a lot of things that had been puzzling to me. So here's a good example-- it's from an interview I did at the 92nd Street Y in New York, with the economist, Richard Thaler, who is one of the leading lights in what's called Behavioral Economics. He had a book coming out called Misbehaving. And I really liked it. And we thought it would be fun if we did an event together.
格兰诺维特的理论解释了很多让我困惑的事情。这里有一个很好的例子——来自我在纽约92街Y中心对经济学家理查德·塞勒进行的采访，他是所谓的“行为经济学”领域的领军人物之一。他有一本即将出版的书叫《错误的行为》。我真的很喜欢它。我们觉得一起做个活动会很有趣。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
You and I have met before. Well, the first time we met was at a hotel bar in Rochester?
你和我也见过面。嗯，我们第一次见面是在罗切斯特的一家酒店酒吧？
Yes.
是的。
Thaler's the kind of guy who's interested in everything, including sports. And there was a point in our conversation when he started to talk about the fact that the owners of professional football teams do things on occasion that are really stupid and inexplicable. Take the professional football draft.
塞勒是一个对万事万物都感兴趣的人，包括体育。在我们的谈话中有一个点，他开始谈论职业橄榄球队的老板有时会做一些真的很愚蠢且无法解释的事情。拿职业橄榄球选秀来说。
For those of you who are not football fans, let me explain. Every year, all the draft-eligible college football players are thrown into a big pool. And the 32 professional football teams pick the players they want, one by one.
对于那些不是橄榄球迷的人，让我解释一下。每年，所有符合选秀资格的大学橄榄球运动员都会被投入一个大池子。然后32支职业橄榄球队一个接一个地挑选他们想要的球员。
The first player taken is the one that people think will be the best professional player. That person gets the biggest salary. The second player taken is the one predicted to be the second-best professional player, and so on. And after every team has picked one player each, they all start again and do another round.
第一个被选中的球员被认为是最好的职业球员。那个人得到最高的薪水。第二个被选中的球员被预测为第二好的职业球员，依此类推。在每支球队各选了一名球员后，他们会再次开始进行下一轮。
Because the players selected in the first round are considered the most valuable, all the teams fight over them. They pay enormous sums of money and construct elaborate deals to try and acquire those high draft picks.
因为在第一轮选中的球员被认为最有价值，所以所有球队都会争夺他们。他们支付巨额资金并精心策划交易，试图获得那些高顺位的选秀权。
The interesting thing about that is there's a market for picks. So you can trade the first pick for, say, half a dozen second-round picks. That's what the market says. Now, that implies that the first pick is five times more valuable than an early pick in the second round.
关于这一点有趣的是，选秀权是有市场的。所以你可以用第一个顺位选秀权交易，比如说，半打第二轮的选秀权。这就是市场的价格。现在，这意味着第一个顺位选秀权的价值是第二轮早期顺位选秀权的五倍。
Thaler and a colleague named Cade Massey decide to analyze this assumption. Was it really true that a first-round pick was worth half a dozen second-round picks?
塞勒和一位叫凯德·梅西的同事决定分析这一假设。第一轮顺位选秀权真的价值半打第二轮顺位选秀权吗？
If you compute the surplus a player provides to his team-- meaning how good his performance is-- minus how much you have to pay him, what we found is these second-round picks are actually more valuable than that first pick. But you could get five of those for that pick. It's the biggest anomaly I've ever found.
如果你计算一名球员为球队提供的盈余——意思是他的表现有多好——减去你必须支付给他的薪水，我们发现这些第二轮选秀权实际上比那个第一顺位选秀权更有价值。但你却可以用那个选秀权换到五个这样的球员。这是我发现的最巨大的异常现象。
The implication of Thaler and Massey's work is that teams should trade away their first-round picks. They should stockpile players in the second and third rounds, who can be paid a lot less and are nearly as good. This is how you build a winning football team.
塞勒和梅西的研究含义是，球队应该交易掉他们的第一轮顺位选秀权。他们应该囤积第二轮和第三轮的球员，这些人薪水可以低得多，而且水平几乎一样好。这就是你打造获胜橄榄球队的方法。
So what was the reaction of NFL teams to Thaler's idea? Well, not long after he and Cade Massey did their research, they got a call from the Washington Redskins.
那么NFL球队对塞勒的想法有什么反应？嗯，在他和凯德·梅西完成研究后不久，他们接到了华盛顿红人队的电话。
It was early in Dan Snyder's tenure as owner. And I met him. And he said, oh, we want to know about this.
那时是丹·斯奈德担任老板初期。我见过他。他说，哦，我们想了解这个。
And he introduced me. He said, I'm going to send my people to see you. And they flew out to Chicago and met with Cade and me.
然后他把我介绍给了别人。他说，我要派我的人去见你。他们飞到芝加哥，和凯德以及我见了面。
And so anyway, we taught his guys-- Dan's guys-- what to do. And then we watched the draft eagerly that year.
总之，我们教了他的手下——丹的手下——该怎么做。然后我们那年热切地观看了选秀。
And what did they see? The Redskins did the exact opposite of what they should have done if they were rational. And they weren't the only ones. Thaler and Massey have consulted for three NFL franchises now, and no one has ever followed their advice.
他们看到了什么？红人队所做的正好与他们如果理性的话应该做的相反。而且他们不是唯一一个。塞勒和梅西现在已经为三家NFL特许经营店担任顾问了，但从来没有人遵循他们的建议。
It gets worse. There's a very respected economist named David Romer, who famously proved that football teams would win more games if they didn't punt, if they simply used all four downs to try and gain 10 yards, as opposed to giving the ball away to their opponents. So since Romer published his work, are NFL teams less likely to punt on fourth down? You guessed it. No.
更糟糕的是。有一位非常受尊敬的经济学家叫大卫·罗默，他著名地证明了如果橄榄球队不弃踢，如果他们干脆利用全部四次进攻机会尝试获得10码，而不是把球权交给对手，他们会赢得更多比赛。所以自从罗默发表了他的研究以来，NFL球队在第四次进攻时弃踢的可能性变小了吗？正如你所猜。没有。
And to tell you how big this is, if you did this right, we think you'd win one game a year more. If you also learned to go for it more often on fourth down, another game and a half. So just being smart, you would win at least two games a year on average.
为了让你知道这有多大影响，如果你能做对这件事，我们认为你每年会多赢一场比赛。如果你也学会了在第四次进攻时更经常地尝试进攻，再多赢一场半。所以只要变得聪明一点，你平均每年至少会多赢两场比赛。
Two extra wins in a 16-game season, just by acting a little bit differently. Who wouldn't do that? But nobody would!
在16场比赛的赛季里多出两场胜利，只要行为稍有不同。谁会不做呢？但没人会做！
Now, is that because they're stupid, because they have irrational beliefs? That was my first thought when I was listening to Thaler talk about his football research. Those dumb football owners.
那么，这是因为他们愚蠢，因为他们有非理性的信念吗？当我听塞勒谈论他的橄榄球研究时，这是我的第一个想法。那些愚蠢的橄榄球老板。
But that can't be right. You don't get to their level by being dumb. Surely this is about thresholds.
但这不可能是对的。你不会因为愚蠢而达到那个层级。这肯定与阈值有关。
Football owners and coaches are a small group of people. They all know each other. They've all done things a certain way for a long time.
橄榄球老板和教练是一小群人。他们都认识彼此。他们长期以来一直以某种方式行事。
And doing things that way has made them a lot of money. They have a high threshold. These are a bunch of grandmothers.
而且以那种方式行事为他们赚了很多钱。他们有很高的阈值。这是一群祖母。
The only way any of them is going to change their behavior is if some radical goes first. And there are no radical owners in the NFL. There's just Richard Thaler, a geeky middle-aged economist from the University of Chicago, with a bunch of equations that you need a PhD to understand.
他们中任何人改变行为的唯一途径是如果有激进分子先行一步。而NFL中没有激进的老板。只有理查德·塞勒，一个来自芝加哥大学的书呆子中年经济学家，手里拿着一堆需要博士学位才能看懂的方程。
There's some geek at every team who's read our paper. You know, think of the Jonah Hill character in the movie Moneyball , right? And nobody pays attention to that guy.
每支球队都有一些读过我们论文的极客。你知道，想想电影《点球成金》里的乔纳·希尔角色，对吧？没人理会那个家伙。
Apparently there aren't a lot of radicals in basketball either. Just the Barrys, and Chinanu Onuaku, the Nigerian-American who played for Louisville. This, I think, gets us a little closer to the puzzle of Wilt Chamberlain. In his autobiography, he has this throwaway comment on the subject of shooting underhanded.
显然篮球界也没有很多激进分子。只有巴里一家，以及为路易斯维尔效力的尼日利亚裔美国人奇纳努·奥努阿库。我认为这让我们离威尔特·张伯伦的谜团更近了一点。在他的自传中，他关于下手位投篮的话题有一句随口而出的评论。
Chamberlain wrote-- "I felt silly, like a sissy, shooting underhanded. I know I was wrong. I know some of the best foul shooters in history shot that way. Even now, the best one in the NBA, Rick Barry, shoots underhanded. I just couldn't do it."
张伯伦写道——“我感觉自己很傻，像个娘娘腔，用下手位投篮。我知道我是错的。我知道历史上一些最好的罚球手就是那样投的。即使现在，NBA中最好的一个，里克·巴里，也是下手位投篮。我就是做不到。”
Two key things here. First he writes, "I know I was wrong." Just as Granovetter would say, it's not Chamberlain's beliefs that are getting in the way.
这里有两点关键。首先他写道，“我知道我是错的。”正如格兰诺维特所说，阻碍张伯伦的不是他的信念。
He knows it's wrong. Then "I felt silly, like a sissy." His doesn't want to look foolish. He's a high-threshold guy. He needs everyone to be doing something new before he's willing to join in. But Rick Barry? He's different.
他知道这是错的。然后“我感觉自己很傻，像个娘娘腔。”他不想看起来愚蠢。他是一个高阈值的人。他需要每个人都做些新事情，他才愿意加入。但里克·巴里呢？他不同。
Rick Barry's dad comes to him when he's a junior in high school and says, you really ought to shoot underhanded. Rick's a pretty good free throw shooter at that point, maybe 70% or so. But his dad tells him he can do better.
里克·巴里在高二时，他父亲找到他说，你真的应该尝试下手位投篮。里克当时是一个相当不错的罚球手，命中率大约70%左右。但他父亲告诉他，他可以做得更好。
And your initial reaction is I don't want to do it?
而你最初的反应是我不想这样做？
Right.
是的。
Because it seemed to you, like--
因为对你来说看起来，就像——
I said, dad--I always remember it, and I tell people-- Dad, they're going to make fun of me. That's the way the girls shoot. I can't do that. He said, son-- and I remember this so clearly, like it was yesterday-- son, they can't make fun of you if you're making them.
我说，爸爸——我总是记得这件事，我也会告诉别人——爸爸，他们会嘲笑我的。那是女孩投篮的方式。我做不到。他说，孩子——我记得很清楚，就像昨天发生的一样——孩子，如果你的命中率很高，他们就没法嘲笑你。
And the first game I remember where I did it, it was on the road in Scotch Plains, New Jersey. I shot the free throw. Guy in the stands yells out, Hey Barry, you big sissy, shooting like that! And the guy next to him-- and I heard him very clearly-- he says, what are you making fun of him for? He doesn't miss.
我记得我第一次这么做的那场比赛，是在新泽西州斯科奇普莱恩斯的客场。我罚了球。看台上的一个家伙喊道，嘿，巴里，你这大娘娘腔，那样投篮！他旁边的那个人——我听得很清楚——他说，你嘲笑他干什么？他又不投失。
So my dad's prophecy came true. And I was cool from that point forward. So I didn't care anymore what they said. If I'm making 'em, that's all that really matters.
所以我父亲的预言成真了。从那以后我就很酷了。所以我不再在乎别人说什么了。只要我投进，那才是唯一重要的事情。
What's interesting is that Barry actually has the same initial reaction as Wilt Chamberlain-- I'm going to look like a sissy. But he thinks about it, and he decides it doesn't bother him. Or rather, his drive to be a better shooter is stronger than his worry about what others think of him.
有趣的是，巴里实际上有和威尔特·张伯伦相同的最初反应——我会看起来像个娘娘腔。但他思考了一下，决定这并不会困扰他。或者更确切地说，他成为更好射手的驱动力比他对别人如何看他的担忧更强大。
That's exactly what it means to have a low threshold. If you have a threshold of 0, you're someone who doesn't need the support or the approval or the company of others to do what you think is right. Now, here's the catch-- the person who thinks this way is not always easy to be around.
这就是拥有低阈值的真正含义。如果你的阈值是0，你就是一个不需要别人的支持、认可或陪伴来做你认为正确的事情的人。现在，陷阱来了——这样思考的人并不总是容易相处。
Barry was never embraced by his fellow players. There were a couple of notorious articles about him in the 1980s, full of quotes like this from a former teammate-- "If you'd got to know Rick, you'd realize what a good guy he was. But around the league, they thought of him as the most arrogant guy ever." Half the players disliked Rick. The other half hated him. Here's another quote "He lacks diplomacy. If they sent him to the UN, he'd end up starting World War III."
巴里从未被他的队友所拥护。在20世纪80年代有一些臭名昭著的关于他的文章，充满了这样的前队友语录——“如果你深入了解里克，你就会意识到他是一个多么好的人。但在联盟里，他们认为他是史上最傲慢的人。”一半的球员不喜欢里克。另一半恨他。这是另一段语录：“他缺乏外交手腕。如果他们把他派往联合国，他最终会引发第三次世界大战。”
Yeah, well I was about winning. I was about giving my best effort. And I had a very difficult time accepting the fact-- I wouldn't accept the fact-- if a teammate is not going to play his hardest.
是啊，好吧，我追求的是胜利。我追求的是尽我最大的努力。而且我非常难以接受——我不会接受——如果队友不全力以赴的话。
Barry's been out of the game for more than 30 years. But just talking about basketball made him tense. There was a right way to play the game. And when people didn't play it the right way, it drove him crazy.
巴里离开赛场已经超过30年了。但仅仅谈论篮球就让他紧张。打比赛有一种正确的方法。而当人们不用正确的方法打球时，这会让他抓狂。
Watch a game, right? Guy shoots free throw, misses. Everybody goes up, slaps his hand. What the-- where the hell did that come from?
看一场比赛，对吧？家伙罚球，投失。每个人都走过去，拍他的手。那是什么——那到底是从哪儿来的？
I want to know who the guy is that started doing that, and who was the genius that said, man, that's a great idea. Let's go up and slap the guy's hand. And let's go up, disturb his concentration, when he's supposed to be focusing on shooting his free throws, and worry about having to slap the hands of his teammates.
我想知道是谁开始那样做的，又是哪个天才说，嘿，那是个好主意。让我们走过去拍那家伙的手吧。当他应该专注于罚球时，去打扰他的专注，还要担心去拍队友的手。
Do you hear what upsets him? The social part of the game. Players paying attention to each other's feelings as opposed to their own performance.
你听见是什么让他感到困扰了吗？比赛的社交部分。球员关注彼此的感受，而不是他们自己的表现。
Plus the fact if he misses it, you should go up and smack him in the head for missing the free throw, not slap him on the hands and saying it's OK. Because it's not OK. You just cost us a point.
加上如果他投丢了，你应该走过去在他的头上猛敲一下，而不是拍拍他的手说没关系。因为这不没关系。你刚才让我们损失了一分。
I mean, I go nuts when I watch this kind of stuff. And nobody even talks about that. And it's something that somebody brought up, somebody copied, and now everybody does it. And it's stupid. I just have a real problem with that.
我是说，我看这种东西时会发疯。甚至没人谈论它。这是某人提出来的，某人模仿的，现在每个人都这么做。这很愚蠢。我对此真的很有意见。
Barry wrote an autobiography in 1972, called Confessions of a Basketball Gypsy , which I have to say, is one of the strangest autobiographies I've ever read. There are sections of the book Barry gives over to various people in his life. They each write a few pages. And he seems to care not one iota about what these people say about him.
巴里在1972年写了一本自传，叫《篮球吉普赛的忏悔》，我不得不说，这是我读过最奇怪的自传之一。书中有些部分是巴里交给生活中各种人的。他们每人写了几页。他似乎一点也不在乎这些人对他说了什么。
So here's his mother, comparing Barry to his older brother, Dennis. "Rick has become famous and made a lot of money. But what is that? I think maybe, Dennis leads the better life."
这是他母亲把巴里和他哥哥丹尼斯做对比。“里克出名了赚了很多钱。但这算什么？我想也许，丹尼斯过着更好的生活。”
And this is his ex-wife, describing how they first met. "He was awful to me. He was always shoving me in the pool, and I hated him for it.
这是他的前妻，描述他们第一次见面时的样子。“他对我很糟糕。他总是把我推到水池里，我因此很恨他。”
Oh, I could take it. But there's always someone who goes too far, who does it more than the others, beyond endurance. And for me, that was Rick." I would not let my parents and my wife say these things about me in my own autobiography.
哦，我可以忍受。但总有人做得太过分，比别人做得多，超越了忍耐限度。对我来说，那就是里克。我不会让我的父母和妻子在我的自传里说这些关于我的话。
I let people say what they wanted. I didn't ask for editorial rights, to be able to go through and see what they said and see, well no, I don't want that in there. I let them say what they wanted to say.
我让人们说他们想说的。我没有要求编辑权，无法翻阅看看他们说了什么，我想，哦不，我不想把它放进去。我让他们说他们想说的话。
He doesn't care. The kind of person who would let bad things be said about him in his own autobiography is the kind of person who would shoot a free throw that other people think looks ridiculous. I spent an afternoon with Barry at his condo.
他不在乎。那个会在自己的自传里让人说自己坏话的人，就是那种会采用别人看起来觉得荒谬的姿势罚球的人。我和巴里在他的公寓里度过了一个下午。
And I'd read all that stuff about him-- half the players disliked him, the other half hated him. And I kind of braced myself before I met him. But I liked him.
我读过所有关于他的文章——一半球员不喜欢他，另一半恨他。我在见他之前做好了心理准备。但我喜欢他。
Or maybe it makes more sense to say, that I really admired him. Because I finally understood what someone like Rick Barry stands for. It's perfectionism.
或者说，我很钦佩他可能更合理。因为我终于理解了一个像里克·巴里这样的人所代表的东西。那就是完美主义。
And what is a perfectionist? Someone who puts the responsibility of mastering the task at hand ahead of all social considerations, who would rather be right than liked. And how can you be good at something complex, how can you reach your potential if you don't have a little bit of that inside you?
什么是完美主义者？一个把掌握手头任务的责任置于所有社交考虑之上的人，宁愿做正确的事也不愿被人喜欢。如果你的内心没有一点这种东西，你怎么能在一件复杂的事情上变得优秀，你怎么能发挥你的潜能呢？
I know we've really only been talking about basketball, which is just a game in the end. But the lesson here is much bigger than that. It takes courage to be good, social courage, to be honest with yourself, to do things the right way. I think Barry understands the price he's paid for being the way he is. It kept coming up.
我知道我们一直在谈论篮球，这归根结底只是一场游戏。但这里的教训远不止于此。做一个优秀的人需要勇气，社交勇气，对自己诚实，以正确的方式做事。我认为巴里理解他因为成为现在的自己所付出的代价。这总是被提出来。
I'm a good friend. I'm going to be honest with you. I'm going to be there if you need me. I'm a good person. Yet, a lot of people don't think I am.
我是一个好朋友。我会对你诚实。如果你需要我，我会一直在那儿。我是一个好人。然而，很多人并不这么认为。
He's not describing an easy life. But think of what he gained. Rick Barry was the best basketball player he could possibly have been. And Wilt Chamberlain could never say that.
他描述的不是一种轻松的生活。但想想他获得了什么。里克·巴里是他所能成为的最优秀的篮球运动员。而威尔特·张伯伦永远无法那样说。
It's almost incomprehensible to me that someone could have that attitude, to sacrifice their success over worrying about how somebody feels about you or says about you. That's sad, really.
我几乎无法理解一个人怎么会有那样的态度，为了担心别人的感受或别人对你的评价而牺牲自己的成功。那真的很悲哀。
Barry says that years after the two of them stopped playing, he used to go to Wilt Chamberlain, and tell him, you should have come to me. I could have helped you.
巴里说，在他们俩停止打球多年后，他过去常去找威尔特·张伯伦，告诉他，你应该来找我。我本可以帮你的。
Malcolm Gladwell, he's the host of the brand new podcast, Revisionist History . It's produced by Panoply. It's free, and you can subscribe at www.revisionisthistory.com. Coming up-- those who don't pump Trump, hit a bump, get stumped, now chumps. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
马尔科姆·格拉德威尔，他是全新播客《修正主义历史》的主持人。由Panoply制作。它是免费的，你可以在www.revisionisthistory.com订阅。接下来——那些不为特朗普助威的人，撞到障碍，被难住，现在成了蠢货。那是在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme. Today's show, choosing wrong, the stories of people looking at the right choice, considering the right choice, and then rejecting the right choice.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题。今天的节目，做出错误的选择，人们看着正确的选择，考虑正确的选择，然后拒绝正确选择的故事。
So coincidentally, the week that we were making this show, there was this big vote in Britain. And now people in Britain are fretting over the choices. Some of them are, anyway. Tom, for example, is 23.
所以巧合的是，在我们制作这期节目的那一周，英国进行了那次大投票。现在英国的人们正在为他们的选择而苦恼。无论如何，其中一些人是。例如，汤姆，他23岁。
He voted to leave the European Union, and then woke up the next day to see Britain's currency plunge to the lowest level in 30 years. The stock market crashed. The prime minister resigned-- because of his vote and people like him.
他投票支持离开欧盟，第二天醒来看到英国货币跌至30年来的最低水平。股票市场崩盘。首相辞职——因为他的投票和像他这样的人。
It was shocking. It was scary. And I think there was a lot of people that was scared as well. They were unsure that they'd done the right thing. It's just jumping into the unknown, isn't it? No one really knows what was going to happen.
这令人震惊。这很可怕。我想也有很多人很害怕。他们不确定自己是否做了正确的事。这简直就是跳入未知，对吧？没人真正知道会发生什么。
People did predict that British stocks and currency would drop if they left the EU. Tom says he didn't totally understand the pros and cons of Brexit. So in the end, he just voted his feelings.
人们确实预言如果他们离开欧盟，英国股市和货币会下跌。汤姆说他并没有完全理解英国脱欧的利弊。所以最后，他只是凭自己的感觉投票。
I didn't really know what to vote for. But I just felt like, I kind of think it was a guess. I'm kind of regretting it now.
我真的不知道投什么。但我只是觉得，我感觉这更像是一个猜测。我现在有点后悔了。
What do you do for work?
你是做什么工作的？
I work in a bank.
我在银行工作。
You do?
真的吗？
Yeah. So the shares, you know, at work, they did drop.
是的。所以股票，你知道，在工作单位，它们确实下跌了。
Did they drop a lot?
跌了很多吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Which brings us to Act 2, in which people in our country-- political experts, in fact-- second guess their own political judgments with the benefit of hindsight. Anybody can get this stuff wrong. Act 2 of our show is called "Poll Dance".
这把我们带到了第二幕，在这一幕中，我们国家的人们——事实上是政治专家——在事后诸葛亮的情况下重新审视他们自己的政治判断。任何人都有可能在这些事情上犯错。我们节目的第二幕叫做“民调之舞”。
So when Donald Trump won the Republican nomination, the media was surprised. Well, to be more precise, what happened over the course of a few months, there was this slow dawning realization, like, oh, this is really happening? Oh, how did we not see this?
所以当唐纳德·特朗普赢得共和党提名时，媒体感到惊讶。好吧，更确切地说，在几个月的时间里发生了什么，有一种缓慢的觉醒，就像，哦，这真的在发生吗？哦，我们怎么没看到这个？
But the funny thing is now, when you look back on the polling data, you can see, actually, the evidence was there, ready to be seen, that Trump was going to win. And it had been there for months. And most of the media whose job it is to read the polls and the politics correctly and predict what would happen, they just got it wrong.
但有趣的是现在，当你回看民调数据时，你可以看到，其实证据就在那里，准备被发现，特朗普将会赢。而且已经持续了几个月。而大部分工作是正确解读民调和政治并预测会发生什么的人，他们就是搞错了。
Perhaps the most epic of these failures came with the website FiveThirtyEight, which is a journalistic outfit whose entire reason for existence is to predict outcomes, and not in the vague imprecise way that political pundits have always in the past, by interpreting insider gossip and reporting about the candidates. FiveThirtyEight is backed up by data. It's entirely about numbers and using statistical analysis.
也许这些失败中最史诗级的来自网站FiveThirtyEight，这是一个新闻机构，其存在的全部理由是预测结果，而不是像政治评论员过去那样通过解读内幕八卦和报道候选人而以模糊、不精确的方式。FiveThirtyEight是有数据支持的。这完全是关于数字和使用统计分析。
FiveThirtyEight called every single state correctly in the last presidential election. They are just spectacular at political prediction, totally bungled it on this one. Zoe Chace went to talk to them about how exactly they got it wrong.
FiveThirtyEight在上次总统大选中正确预测了每一个州。他们在政治预测方面简直精彩绝伦，这次却完全搞砸了。佐伊·蔡斯去采访了他们，了解他们到底是怎么搞错的。
FiveThirtyEight is the first to say they screwed this up. And at FiveThirtyEight, if you get something wrong, you go back into the data and you figure out why what happened happened, and why you got it wrong. And then explain that with more data. I talked with one of their senior writers, Harry Enten.
FiveThirtyEight是第一家说他们搞砸了的机构。而在FiveThirtyEight，如果你犯了错，你就会回到数据中，找出为什么会发生这样的事情，为什么你犯了错。然后用更多的数据解释它。我采访了他们的资深作家之一，哈里·恩滕。
So let's talk about Trump.
让我们谈谈特朗普。
Donald Trump.
唐纳德·特朗普。
Yeah, that guy. So I want to ask you to read something to me. And I'm not trying to torture you. I'm just trying to set the mood here, of what we're going to be covering.
是的，那个家伙。所以我想请你为我读点东西。我不是想折磨你。我只是想营造一种氛围，关于我们将要报道的内容。
Basically, when Trump had just decided to enter the race, you wrote something. What did you write? Can you read it to me?
基本上，当特朗普刚决定参加竞选时，你写了一些东西。你写了什么？你能为我读读吗？
Are we talking about Why Donald Trump Isn't a Real Candidate in One Chart? Is that the piece we're referring to.
我们是在谈论《为什么在一张图表中唐纳德·特朗普不是一个真正的候选人》吗？这是我们指的那篇文章吗？
Yeah, by Harry Enten.
是的，哈里·恩滕写的。
By Harry Enten. Ah, OK. So "Trump has a better chance of cameoing in another Home Alone movie with Macaulay Culkin, or playing in the NBA Finals, than winning the Republican nomination."
哈里·恩滕写的。啊，好吧。所以“特朗普在另一部《小鬼当家》电影中与麦考利·卡尔金客串，或在NBA总决赛中打球的机会，都比赢得共和党提名要大。”
He wrote that a year ago, just before Trump entered the race. When I first heard Harry talk, I assumed he was about 60 years old, because he says stuff like this--
他一年前写的，就在特朗普加入竞选之前。当我第一次听到哈里说话时，我以为他大概60岁，因为他说这样的话——
We'll get another primary, God willing, if I'm alive for that primary, in four years. And--
如果我有幸活到那次初选，我们四年后会迎来另一次初选。而且——
In fact, he's a 28-year-old stats nerd. He describes his job like this--
事实上，他是一个28岁的统计书呆子。他这样描述他的工作——
I'm looking at a lot of different data. I've researched a lot of past years. I've downloaded data. I've looked into files. I've built my own data. Because sometimes the original data is in such a messy case, whereby, I have to piece together data.
我正在查看很多不同的数据。我研究了很多过去的年份。我下载了数据。我查阅了文件。我建立了属于我自己的数据。因为有时原始数据处于一种非常混乱的状态，我不得不拼凑数据。
And at the end of every year he does a piece about what he got wrong. In 2015, it was Trump. And let me say, you do a story on what you got wrong if you get most things right. Harry's usually very on point. So what did he miss?
而在每年结束时，他都会写一篇关于他做错的内容。2015年，是特朗普。容我说一句，如果你大部分事情都做对了，你才会写一个关于你做错什么的故事。哈里通常非常精准。那么他错过了什么？
It's really as simple as this-- if all I was looking at was the horse race polling numbers, if all I was looking at were the polls, if I had trusted the polls, if I had trusted that people, when they said they were going to vote for Donald Trump, would vote for Donald Trump, then I would have said that Donald Trump was going to be the Republican nominee, and probably as early as August of 2015.
实际上就像这样简单——如果我所看的一切只是竞选民调数字，如果我所看的一切只是民调，如果我信任这些民调，如果我相信当人们说他们要投票给唐纳德·特朗普时，他们就会投票给唐纳德·特朗普，那么我会说唐纳德·特朗普将成为共和党候选人，而且可能早在2015年8月就会说了。
And why didn't you?
而你为什么没说？
The reason we didn't look at those polls was because Trump's lead was A, not necessarily all that big. But B, in the past we had seen candidates who lead in the early polls and then did not become nominees. And they were pretty clear.
我们没有看那些民调的原因是因为特朗普的领先优势A，不一定有那么大。但B，在过去我们见过那些在早期民调中领先但最终没有成为候选人的候选人。而且他们很明确。
I mean, just go back to four years ago. Michele Bachmann was leading in Iowa in the early polls. Herman Cain was leading in the early polls. Newt Gingrich was leading in the early polls, Rick Perry. And they didn't go on to win nominations. You go back to '08, Rudy Giuliani led in the national primary polls, and his entire bid fell apart.
我是说，回到四年前。米歇尔·巴赫曼在早期民调中在爱荷华州领先。赫尔曼·凯恩在早期民调中领先。纽特·金里奇在早期民调中领先，还有里克·佩里。但他们最终都没有赢得提名。回到08年，鲁迪·朱利安尼在全国初选民调中领先，但他整个竞选都分崩离析了。
No respectable analyst takes the horse race polls too seriously. One minute you're up, the next you're down. No context, no long-term meaning. Harry ignored them. Instead, he wanted to look at something that has a history of being right, not a history of being inflated by the media coverage of the moment.
没有受人尊敬的分析师会太认真对待竞选民调。这一分钟你领先，下一分钟你落后。没有背景，没有长期意义。哈里忽略了它们。相反，他想看一些有被证明正确历史的东西，而不是被当时媒体报道膨胀的东西。
The data he focused on the morning Trump announced his bid was what he'd seen be a good predictor before-- favorability. Do people like this candidate? It's just how people answer this question.
特朗普宣布参选那天早上他关注的数据是他以前见过的良好预测指标——好感度。人们喜欢这个候选人吗？这只是人们如何回答这个问题。
Do you have a favorable or unfavorable view of businessman, Donald Trump? And the question is usually is as simple as that. And what we've found in the past was that that type of question, although it couldn't tell you who would necessarily win a nomination, it would tell you who probably wouldn't win a nomination.
你对商人唐纳德·特朗普持好感还是反感？这个问题通常就这么简单。而我们在过去发现，那种类型的问题，虽然不能告诉你谁一定会赢得提名，但它可以告诉你谁可能不会赢得提名。
And essentially, what I did was I threw together a chart in which I looked at all these presidential candidates who had run since 1980, and said, OK, how popular were they? And I essentially looked at that data. And I said, wow, Donald Trump is really unpopular.
而本质上，我所做的是把所有自1980年以来竞选的总统候选人放在一张图表中，说，好吧，他们有多受欢迎？我本质上查看了那些数据。我说，哇，唐纳德·特朗普真的很不受欢迎。
He's a lot more unpopular than previous candidates who have won the nomination. And pretty much, a lot more unpopular than candidates who even run for major party nominations. I mean, in reality, no one was even anywhere close to being as disliked as Donald Trump and went on to win a nomination.
他比以前赢得提名的候选人要不受欢迎得多。而且几乎比那些竞选主要政党提名的候选人都要不受欢迎得多。我是说，实际上，根本没有人像唐纳德·特朗普那样被讨厌却最终赢得了提名。
But what Harry couldn't see was what was about to happen next in this race. The day Trump announced his candidacy, June 16th of last year, Trump gave a speech, the highlight of which was this--
但哈里无法看到接下来在这个竞选中会发生什么。特朗普宣布竞选资格的那天，也就是去年6月16日，特朗普发表了演讲，其中亮点是这个——
I would build a great wall. And nobody builds walls better than me, believe me. I will build a great, great wall on our southern border. And I will have Mexico pay for that wall. Mark my words.
我会筑起一堵伟大的墙。而且没人比我更擅长筑墙，相信我。我将在我们的南部边境修建一堵宏伟的墙。而且我会让墨西哥支付那堵墙的费用。记住我的话。
And right after this speech, those favorability numbers turned upside down. Trump went from minus 35 to plus 17. More Republican primary voters had a favorable view of Trump than an unfavorable one. It was a really big turnaround.
而就在这次演讲之后，那些好感度数字颠倒了。特朗普从负35变成了正17。更多的共和党初选选民对特朗普持好感而非反感。这是一个非常大的转折。
That switch, from negative 35 to positive 17 is just really unusual. I don't think I've ever seen that before. And it was something that I couldn't have possibly have predicted. But I wish that when I saw that, I might have said, hmm, maybe these numbers are more malleable than we thought on Trump. Maybe we have to be a little more cautious.
那个切换，从负35到正17，确实非常罕见。我想我以前从来没见过这种情况。这是我根本无法预测的事情。但我希望当我看到那个时，我可能会说，嗯，也许这些数字比我们想的关于特朗普的要灵活。也许我们必须稍微谨慎一点。
Harry thinks that of everything Trump said that day, it was probably the wall that pushed his numbers the most. Because other pollings showed that of the voters who said immigration was their number one issue, Trump was far and away their favorite guy.
哈里认为，特朗普那天所说的一切中，大概是那堵墙最能推动他的数字。因为其他民调显示，在那些说移民是他们头号问题的选民中，特朗普远非他们最喜欢的家伙。
He was more trusted on the issue of immigration than any of the other candidates were. So to me, it was very clear, looking at the polling, that the more that the discussion focused on immigration, the more Donald Trump benefited from it.
在移民问题上，他比其他任何候选人都更受信任。所以对我来说，看民调很清楚，讨论越集中在移民问题上，唐纳德·特朗普从中受益就越多。
So that data was out there. But still, Harry ignored it. He didn't see the truth. He still thought that Trump couldn't win. Here's Harry back in October, 2015, on the FiveThirtyEight Elections Podcast, which is a great podcast, by the way.
所以那个数据就在那里。但哈里还是忽略了它。他没看到真相。他依然认为特朗普不会赢。这是哈里在2015年10月，在FiveThirtyEight选举播客上，顺便说一句，这是一个很棒的播客。
Trump is just somebody who is a show. It's a show. People are interested in a show. Politics as reality TV. When it gets down to actual voting, we've seen over and over again, shows do well early. But then actual politicians tend to do well late.
特朗普只是一个表演。这是一个表演。人们对表演感兴趣。政治即真人秀。当落实到实际投票时，我们一次又一次地看到，表演在早期做得很好。但真正的政客往往在后期做得很好。
A few weeks ago, when Harry went back to dissect what he got wrong, he found something else, something important. In fact, the biggest thing that he'd missed the first time. It was in those favorability numbers.
几周前，当哈里回去剖析他做错的地方时，他发现了别的东西，一些重要的东西。事实上，他第一次错过的最大的一点。它就在那些好感度数字里。
If you look deeper into those numbers, there was one very significant group of voters. These were the people who told pollsters their view of Trump was not just favorable, it was strongly favorable. These are the diehards. They will not change their minds.
如果你深入查看那些数字，有一组非常重要的选民。这些人告诉民调员他们对特朗普的看法不仅是好感，而且是强烈好感。这些人是死忠。他们不会改变主意。
Think of this group as the Deadheads who actually go on tour with the band. Trump had this core group of strongly favorables that he could rely on in every primary. It was solid. It was a superpower that no one else in the field had.
把这群人想象成实际上跟随乐队巡演的“死之华”乐队粉丝。特朗普拥有这群他可以在每一次初选中依赖的强烈好感核心群体。它很稳固。这是现场其他人所没有的超能力。
Trump's strongly favorable rating was 30% in that ABC News Washington Post poll by early July. 30%, which was basically where he was polling at for a lot of the primary season. You know, sometimes he was a little bit below 30, in the 20s. Sometimes he was a little bit above 30, say about 35%.
特朗普的强烈好感度评级在7月初的ABC新闻《华盛顿邮报》民调中为30%。30%，这基本上是他初选季节大部分时间里的民调水平。你知道，有时他会稍微低于30%，在20多%。有时他会稍微高于30%，大约在35%左右。
And that is a very important ally to have when the field is 15, 16, however many candidates we ended up with. Because that means that all you really need-- remember, what percentage of the vote did he win in the South Carolina primary? He won only 32%. That's right around that 30%.
当现场有15、16名甚至更多候选人时，这是一个非常重要的盟友。因为这意味着你真正需要的——记住，他在南卡罗来纳州初选中赢得了百分之多少的选票？他只赢了32%。那就在30%左右。
Now, Harry saw the 30%. But at the time, he completely misunderstood it. Instead of seeing it as the army that would win primary after primary, instead of seeing it as Trump's super power, he thought it was a problem for Trump.
现在，哈里看到了这30%。但在当时，他完全误解了它。他没把它看作会赢得一场又一场初选的军队，没把它看作特朗普的超能力，反而认为它是特朗普的一个问题。
He thought the 30% was a ceiling, the maximum that Trump could get. I remember at the time, FiveThirtyEight and lots of political writers were saying, this was Trump's Achilles heel. He would never be able to get more than 30% of Republicans to like him. In retrospect, Harry says, it wasn't a ceiling.
他以为这30%是一个天花板，特朗普能得到的最高水平。我记得当时，FiveThirtyEight和许多政治作家说，这是特朗普的阿喀琉斯之踵。他永远无法让超过30%的共和党人喜欢他。回顾过去，哈里说，这不是天花板。
That 30% might have been more of a floor. That is, that there was this 30% of the public who really, really like Donald Trump, and would vote for him no matter what. He could count on that 30% that was going to be there for him through thick and thin.
那30%可能更像是一个底部。也就是说，有这30%的公众真的、非常喜欢唐纳德·特朗普，无论如何都会投票给他。他可以指望这30%的人会不离不弃地支持他。
Versus say, a candidate like Jeb Bush, who may have had a number of people at the beginning saying, well, I have a more favorable view of Jeb Bush than of Donald Trump. But those views aren't really strongly held. They aren't something that I wouldn't be willing to give up the more information I learn about Jeb Bush.
相比之下，像杰布·布什这样的候选人，可能在开始时有一部分人说，嗯，我对杰布·布什的好感度比唐纳德·特朗普高。但这些观点并不是真的非常坚定。这不是我不愿意放弃的东西，当我了解到更多关于杰布·布什的信息时。
Which is exactly what happened to Jeb Bush. The longer he was in, the more his numbers fell. Even though he was the early party pick, the establishment favorite, the second heir to the throne. There's a theory in political science called The Party Decides. And most people thought the Republican elite would be the ones to pick the Republican candidate.
这正是发生在杰布·布什身上的事情。他待的时间越长，他的数字就越低。即使他是早期的党内人选、建制派的最爱、皇位的第二继承人。政治学中有一个理论叫《政党决定》。大多数人认为共和党精英会是选择共和党候选人的人。
OK, so another thing that you thought was that the Republican party was in control.
好吧，所以你认为的另一件事是共和党在控制之中。
Oh, how silly I was.
哦，我当时多傻啊。
Yeah.
是的。
How silly I was.
我当时多傻啊。
Well, it's hard to imagine now. But I also remember thinking, oh, it's just not that complicated. The Republican party is not going to allow this to happen. I just assumed that.
好吧，现在很难想象了。但我还记得当时想，哦，这没那么复杂。共和党不会允许这种事情发生。我只是假设了。
And I think a lot of people did. And I guess what I'm wondering, is well, why did you think that? Why did I think it? But why did you think it?
我想很多人都这么想。我想知道的是，好吧，你为什么那么想？我为什么那么想？但你为什么那么想？
Well, what we know in the past is that when one candidate is very well liked by the party elites or the party actors, they tend to win nominations.
嗯，我们过去知道的是，当一位候选人非常受党内精英或党内参与者喜欢时，他们往往会赢得提名。
And when the candidate is not liked, he says, it's the opposite. The party comes together to stop them.
而当候选人不受喜欢时，他说，恰恰相反。党派会联合起来阻止他们。
I'll give you a perfect example. If you go back to the 2012 campaign, and Newt Gingrich starts leading Mitt Romney in a number of primary polls, or then Newt Gingrich wins the South Carolina primary. What you see are a whole bunch of Newt Gingrich's ex-colleagues coming out and saying, he was awful for us.
我可以给你一个完美的例子。如果你回到2012年的竞选，纽特·金里奇开始在一些初选民调中领先米特·罗姆尼，或者然后纽特·金里奇赢得了南卡罗来纳州初选。你看到的是一大堆纽特·金里奇的前同事出来说，他对我们来说太糟糕了。
He was terrible. He led us to disaster. People like Dick Armey, for instance, said that. People like Bob Dole said that.
他太可怕了。他把我们引向灾难。比如像迪克·阿米那样的人说了。像鲍勃·多尔那样的人说了。
Just to show you how different things are this year, the party elite freaked out about Donald Trump. But that didn't stop him. And now, not only has Bob Dole endorsed Trump, but he's advocating for Newt to be Trump's VP, which might mean that Bob Dole actually hates Trump.
为了让你看看今年情况有多不同，党内精英对唐纳德·特朗普感到惊慌。但这并没有阻止他。现在，不仅鲍勃·多尔支持了特朗普，而且他还在主张纽特成为特朗普的副总统，这可能意味着鲍勃·多尔实际上讨厌特朗普。
The whole purpose of the work that's done by people like Harry-- data journalism-- is to essentially draw conclusions that are free of assumptions. There's this one bias I found though, even in the unflappable Harry Enten. FiveThirtyEight has an allergy to media hype. They have this aversion to frothy, splashy coverage of a person or an event.
像哈里这样的人所做的工作——数据新闻——的全部目的，本质上是得出没有假设的结论。我确实发现了一个偏见，即使在泰然自若的哈里·恩滕身上也存在。FiveThirtyEight对媒体炒作有过敏反应。他们对一个人或事件的泡沫化、喧闹的报道有反感。
The bias that we have is towards our priors, to use a Bayesian term, is towards the status quo.
我们拥有的偏见是倾向于我们的先验，用贝叶斯术语来说，是倾向于现状。
Right.
对。
Just meaning it's hard for those guys to admit something new is going on that doesn't fit the model, particularly when it's dressed in hysterical cable-news clothing. And that, I believe, is why Harry and all journalists, basically, missed the real phenomenon lurking underneath the hype.
意思就是说，这些人很难承认有什么新的、不符合模型的事情发生，特别是当它披着歇斯底里的有线电视新闻服装时。而我认为，这就是为什么哈里和所有记者基本上错过了潜伏在炒作之下的真正现象。
OK, I don't mean to ask you a total stoner question here at this point.
好吧，我并不是想在此时此刻问你一个完全像瘾君子一样的问题。
I'm breaking out the weed.
我正要拿出大麻。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, great. Because that's kind of what this question is going to be like--
好的，太棒了。因为这个问题听起来就是那样——
OK, here's my question. Since his statistical models are based on what happened in the past, how can you predict something that's never happened before, like Trump?
好的，这是我的问题。由于他的统计模型是基于过去发生的事情，你如何预测从未发生过的事情，比如特朗普？
Well, sometimes there are ahistorical candidates that you try and fit into history and maybe they shouldn't be. Oftentimes it's not a perfect fit. Usually though, the fit is good enough that it tells us what's going to occur.
嗯，有时会有非历史的候选人，你尝试把他们放入历史中，也许他们不应该被放入。通常这不是完美的契合。不过通常，契合度足够好，能告诉我们将会发生什么。
But apparently in this case, it was not. And maybe we should have been a little more cautious and understood that Trump was a unique character. And what had worked in the past wasn't going to work for him. Because simply put, he broke the mold.
但显然在这个案例中，并不是。也许我们本应该稍微谨慎一点，意识到特朗普是一个独特的人物。过去行得通的东西对他来说行不通。因为简单来说，他打破了模具。
Is it frustrating? Do you feel like, oh this thing that I relied on is not as reliable as I thought?
这令人沮丧吗？你是否觉得，哦，我所依赖的这个东西不如我想象的那么可靠？
Well, of course it's frustrating. Nobody likes to be wrong. I think this is one of the funniest things that people think.
嗯，当然令人沮丧。没人喜欢犯错。我认为这是人们想到的最有趣的事情之一。
Oh, you were biased. Oh you were this. Oh, you know, you've been bought off or whatever. You get that a lot from the Sanders folks.
哦，你有偏见。哦，你是这种人。哦，你知道，你被收买了之类的。从桑德斯支持者那里你经常听到这个。
What a ridiculous concept. You want to get things right! That's what we're here for.
多么荒谬的概念。你想要把事情做对！这就是我们在这儿的原因。
You don't want to get wrong. You don't want people jumping into your Twitter feed or sending you e-mails, telling you you're an idiot. No one wants that.
你不想搞错。你不希望人们跳进你的Twitter信息流或给你发电子邮件，告诉你你是个白痴。没人想要那个。
When you look at the data, you obviously want that data to lead you to the right conclusion. And it's frustrating when you feel like the data that normally had worked lets you down. You want to be able to go to bed at night thinking hey, I'm not a complete fraud.
当你查看数据时，你显然希望数据能引领你得出正确的结论。当你觉得平时行之有效的数据让你失望时，这很令人沮丧。你希望晚上能上床睡觉，心想嘿，我不是一个彻头彻尾的骗子。
The last thing Harry pointed out is this is a really small data set to draw conclusions from-- presidential primaries-- it just is. 1972 is when primaries started actually choosing their party's nominee. There have only been 14 presidential primaries since then, without an incumbent president. So really, in order to see Trump coming clearly, we need to see a lot more Trumps. We need a Trump precedent. Precedent, I said.
哈里指出的最后一点是，这是一个得出结论的数据集非常小——总统初选——事实就是如此。1972年是初选真正开始决定党内提名人选的时候。从那以后，在没有现任总统的情况下，只有14次总统初选。所以确实，为了清楚地看到特朗普的到来，我们需要看到更多的特朗普。我们需要一个特朗普先例。先例，我说的是。
Zoe Chace, she's one of the producers of our program. She takes no position on whether Donald Trump should be president.
佐伊·蔡斯，她是我们的节目制作人之一。她对唐纳德·特朗普是否应该成为总统不持立场。
Act 3, post-it not. So we end our show today with this example of somebody knowingly choosing wrong. In this case, choosing wrong for his own amusement. Comedian Kurt Braunohler tells the story.
第三幕，便利贴。所以我们今天以某人明知故犯地做出错误选择的例子结束我们的节目。在这个案例中，为了自己的消遣而做出错误选择。喜剧演员库尔特·布劳诺勒讲了这个故事。
I've been writing all of my stand up on these giant poster-sized post-it notes. They're, like, big. And so when you come into the first room of my apartment, it is literally covered in my writing.
我一直在这些巨大的海报大小的便利贴上写我所有的脱口秀段子。它们，很大。所以当你走进我公寓的第一个房间时，它实际上覆盖着我的笔记。
And my friend, Albertina, came over the other day. And she was, like, you can't bring a woman back here because you look like the Unabomber. And I was, like, these are all funny jokes.
我的朋友艾伯蒂娜前几天过来。她说，你不能带女人回这儿，因为你看起来像大学炸弹客。我说，这些都是有趣的笑话。
And she said, it just says here, "Do bad decisions exist?" And I was, like, that's a funny joke. And she's, like, that's a [BLEEP] crazy-person thought.
她说，这里只写着，“坏决定存在吗？”我说，那是个有趣的笑话。她说，那是个[哔声]疯子的想法。
But this was her idea. She said, what you should do is you should write on your wall, "List of people I need to kill". And then have, like, eight names with the first one crossed off.
但这主意是她的。她说，你应该做的是在墙上写上，“我需要杀掉的人名单”。然后列出八个名字，把第一个划掉。
I was, like, that is funny. So I did that. And then I thought it would be even funnier if the last name just said Random.
我说，那很有趣。所以我那样做了。然后我觉得如果最后一个名字写着“随机”会更有趣。
So then flash forward, like, three months. And I have finally convinced a young lady to come back to my apartment with me. And as I'm putting the key in the door, I remember that I have a list of people I need to kill on my wall that needs some explaining.
所以快进，三个月后。我终于说服了一位年轻女士和我一起回到我的公寓。当我把钥匙插进门锁时，我记得我的墙上有一个我需要杀掉的人的名单，需要解释一下。
The door opened. She sees it. She freezes.
门开了。她看到了。她惊呆了。
I kind of go into repair mode. I'm like, I'm a comedian. This is a joke. And I calm her down.
我进入了维修模式。我说，我是喜剧演员。这是个笑话。我让她冷静下来。
But then I just can't help myself. And I slowly cross off Random.
但我就是忍不住。我慢慢地划掉了“随机”。
Kurt Braunohler, he's a stand-up comedian and recording his first one-hour special for Comedy Central this September. That clip was courtesy of Comedy Central.
库尔特·布劳诺勒，他是一位脱口秀喜剧演员，今年九月正在为喜剧中心录制他的第一个一小时特别节目。那个片段由喜剧中心提供。
Well, our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis. Our production staff, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robin Semien, Lyra Smith, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney and Nancy Updike. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Editorial help from Julie Snyder and Elna Baker. Music help from Damien Gray, from Rob Gettis.
嗯，我们的节目今天由达纳·奇维斯制作。我们的制作团队，佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦、罗宾·塞米恩、莱拉·史密斯、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。编辑帮助来自朱莉·斯奈德和埃尔纳·贝克。音乐帮助来自达米安·格雷，来自罗伯·盖蒂斯。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS].
[鸣谢]。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His reaction to the Brexit vote? No surprise, same as usual.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）传送到公共广播电台。感谢，一如既往，我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。他对英国脱欧投票的反应？不意外，和往常一样。
I'm breaking out the weed.
我正要拿出大麻。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。